good evening I'm Elizabeth lindenmayer
am the director of the United Nations
program here at Secca and I want to
welcome you all to our panel on the
development challenges at the United
Nations in a time of multiple crises and
the role of women in development I just
want to tell you that this panel is
co-sponsored by the economic and
political development concentration by
the human right concentration by the
humanitarian affairs program and the
Institute for Latin American Studies
it's really a great honor for me to
introduce you tonight as the moderator
of the panel the administrator of undp
Helen Clark she is coming for the first
time a CIPA she is the first woman at
the head of undp she really is a role
model for many young women in the world
and certainly at ciba she's a leader
herself and prior to coming to the
United Nations she was the prime
minister of New Zealand three times in a
row and I believe that she was also the
first woman as the prime minister of New
Zealand she was there from nineteen
ninety nine to two thousand eight she
also while she was the Prime Minister
belong to the Council of women for world
leaders which is a network of a
high-level women who try to mobilize
attention on important issues and the
issue of woman has always been I think
on her agenda she she is really I think
a person who can speak about development
challenges like nobody else can for many
different reasons but I would like her
to welcome you with a big applause
because that is her first time at the
school so
tomorrow at the United Nations
headquarters they will be emitting
hosted by the secretary-general and the
united states in cooperation with the
haitian government it will be a
high-level donor conference and it will
be called toward the future for haiti
and i just would like to use this
opportunity perhaps to thank you NDP and
through Helen Clark all her staff for
the incredible support that myself and
six of my students receive while we were
in Haiti during the earthquake it just
happened that our last meeting we had
finished a week of meeting and a last
meeting was with undp and we were just
in front of the building getting out of
the van when the earthquake struck and
we spent a whole night on the undp
compound and we were evacuated to the
logistic base of Minister Liu following
morning thanks to UNDP and I really want
to express my appreciation because I do
believe that if we come back alive the
seven of us is probably because of the
support of undp thank you you know about
the devastating earthquake which struck
in Haiti on in a January and which
killed more than 220,000 people which
affected more than 1.5 million people
and 1.3 people are really in temporary
shelters just now intense and are facing
the rainy season which has started as
well as the hurricane season and the
conference tomorrow will be to see how
we can help the government of Haiti
rebuild its country but also how can you
ensure a smooth transition between the
humanitarian assistance phase in which
city is still very much into to a
recovery phase and long-term development
and that will be a huge challenge for
everyone in September again at the
United Nations
will be a 10 year with you submit on the
mdgs on the Millennium Development Goals
which is another challenge and
development and everybody all the member
states the united nations will review
the commitment of ten years ago and talk
about the strategies which could be used
to reach the goals in 2015 the goals
which we r sub set up ten years ago but
these are just two examples of
development challenges I'm sure that
Helen Clark will have many more to speak
about the challenges are down ting as
you know but whether they flow from
conflicts or from the global Lee global
the global economic crises or from the
financial crises all natural disasters
like haiti and chile and turkey undp is
involved and therefore i cannot think
they have 135 offices i believe around
the world they on the ground all the
time they you know from Iraq to
Afghanistan from high 82 Congo to
Liberia they are all over the place and
I can't think of a better person to talk
to you tonight about the challenges of
the challenges of development sue Helen
I give you the floor
well thank you Elizabeth for the
introduction and for your kind words
about UNDP and what it does and can I
also acknowledge what a terrifying
experience you and your students have
had in Haiti I want to make some
comments about Haiti ear towards the end
of the remarks I make today but I knew
you had been in Haiti with a group at
the time of the earthquake and we've
just been talking in your office before
coming about what actually happened and
I can only imagine how traumatic it must
have been I went to Haiti four and a
half days after the earthquake and saw
the site of the hotel Christopher which
your group had just left and we all know
what that means so really hearts are
with you because it takes a a long time
of ever to get memories like that away
you just you just can't forget what
happened Elizabeth also reminds me that
to 10 years ago she came to New Zealand
with coffee and nuns delegation I was a
new prime minister and coffee a nun came
to New Zealand as secretary-general of
the United Nations off the back of a
visit to timor-leste I think and he made
wonderful comments about New Zealand at
that time which we very much appreciated
you said that he thought I was the first
woman to be Prime Minister in New
Zealand actually I was the first to win
an election but the way political life
goes when you're on the rise in politics
your opponents will always look for any
way to try and knock you off that path
and so two years before the general
election in New Zealand when we were on
course to win the Conservative Party
which was in government had a palace
coup and they deposed the serving male
prime minister who was aware the
Commonwealth summit and Scotland at the
time and put in a woman leader for two
years and so it was a sort of woman on
woman show for the 1999 general election
so that is the full the full story but I
spent
just over 27 years in the New Zealand
Parliament 12 of them were years in
opposition and 15 and government so I
guess in a democracy that's a pretty
good run isn't it to have a career
divided in in that way and every year of
it of course valuable you know often I'd
go and speak with University classes or
high school classes or even primary
school class that people say how do you
get to be Prime Minister of your country
say it's a long story a very long story
and you have to start by doing all the
little things before you get to do the
big things there's not many examples of
people just parachuting in as with no
with no track record so it was a long
story and if anyone wants to hear about
the long story please ask a question
time but prior to going into the new
zealand Parliament I came from a
background of student and academic life
I spent 14 years of my life prior to
going into Parliament at the University
of Auckland first as a student and then
a number of years as a lecturer in guess
what the Political Studies department so
I guess that was all a preparation as
well but I make the point because I very
much appreciate the role that
universities play in encouraging
informed debate about issues global
issues national issues and this this
month I've been out and about around
universities speaking at Oxford and the
london school of economics at Georgetown
University last week and now with you
and one of the many reasons for doing
that is that I hope in a student
audience like this that there will be
people who listen and who are part of
course a very interesting program here
who might think gosh I would like a
career in development or international
relations with the UN because truly to
keep our organizations vibrant energetic
new ideas we need to attract the best
rightist of each generation and truly
some very remarkable people have been
through the international organizations
of the UN so maybe someone today will
think well that that could be me I could
have a career of that kind so this
program of course in the school has very
strong ties to the UN we are in the Doug
Hummer schult auditorium after all which
which sums up the importance of the
connection a very very important former
secretary-general of the United Nations
and I know that the work of United
Nations Studies program is about
fostering a greater understanding of
what happens in the UN and not so far
from this very University and the UN has
this is the lead into what I want to say
about development a critical role in
helping tackle the multiple crises which
affect our world year in year out day in
day out month in month out and we need a
strong multilateral system to deal with
these issues the truth is one decade
into the 21st century the world is
rather struggling to come to grips with
a whole lot of often interconnected
problems they affect all of us and they
impact particularly severely on
development wouldn't take a genius to
work out what the series of crises are
the world has just been through the
worst economic recession and crisis
since the Great Depression of the 1930s
which my parents had etched in their
memory go back just a couple of years to
the very sharp increases and food prices
a food crisis literally and frankly food
prices are still at rather high levels
if you're a small food exporting country
like New Zealand of course high food
prices is a wonderful thing the current
account and gross domestic product but
what misery those very high prices
causing to so many people in 2008 we
also saw a huge spike in oil prices
fantastic if you're an oil exporter but
most countries aren't and so that
impacts very severely particularly on
the developing countries then we have
the ongoing climate issues the climate
disasters alongside the many other
natural disasters Haiti Chile turkey so
many collectively causing great loss of
life and lighting development prospects
and then think around the world to the
various wars and conflicts which throw
development into reverse gear it's very
hard to get any traction on development
obviously in a war or conflict zone a
number of those crises of course have
impacted on developed countries as well
don't tell me about it I tried to run at
a general election in 2008 when people
complaining about food prices petrol
prices the first impact of the recession
and so on that's tough and I also come
from a country which experiences a wide
range of natural disasters flooding
heavy snow we also have a earthquakes
volcanic activity etc but what I know is
a characteristic of developed countries
as they have resilience they have deep
pockets and it's the lack of deep
pockets and the lack of resilience which
makes these crises particularly damaging
for the countries that I am very much
focused on in my present role and among
of course the most vulnerable people who
feel the impact of a crisis of the most
are the world's women and I want to talk
about the issues as they concern women
and my comments to you tonight I'm a
very strong believer in sustainable
routes out of poverty requiring women to
be full beneficiaries
of their country's development progress
and contributors to their country's
development progress if we sideline
women then we will must development
goals of your sideline half the
population you cannot meet development
goals and yet given a fair go I come
from a country with a concept of a fair
go is very important women will be
tremendous agents of change and forces
for peace and development now let me
link this to the Millennium Development
Goals and the forthcoming summit at the
United Nations in September actually not
so long after coffee and on visited my
country he must have made a strong pitch
to me to go to the millennium summit in
New York and I Julie came up here at
coffees command in September 2000 to
sign the millennium declaration make a
short speech and of course in the
millennium declaration were the eight
millennium development goals of course
when you sign goals which have a 15 year
horizon and it's year 2000 you think
well that's three political lifetimes
away and never in my wildest dreams did
I think I would end up as the
administrator of the United Nations
Development Program and have it as a
major mission to promote these goals so
here we are ten years down five years to
go and we need to review how it's going
and i want to say i believe the goals
could be met can be met can be achieved
that there has been progress but we've
got a number of challenges so let's talk
about both sides of that there have been
sizeable reductions in poverty and child
mortality rates and increases in primary
school enrolment towards the universal
primary schooling and progress towards
access to clean water but that's at the
global level if we break it down for
example on poverty and if we took
China's figures out of the equation
different story the rise of hundreds of
millions of people out of poverty in
China is one of the most amazing stories
of humankind but if we just look at the
figures without China the numbers of
people elsewhere who are living in
extreme poverty is actually estimated to
have increased between 1990 and 2005 and
the millennium development goals are set
from 1990 through 2 2015 and the World
Bank is now telling us that because of
the economic crisis around 64 million
more people this year will be living in
extreme poverty that's on under one
dollar 25 a day then would have been the
case without the recession so the
recession is actually taking us
backwards on that one hunger is on the
rise as well more than a billion people
were estimated by the food and
agriculture organization of the UN to be
chronically hungry last year and those
figures were up around a hundred and
thirty million people on the numbers
prior to the food crisis so what to do
well obviously my organization is
working with many partners partner
governments partner agencies to see what
could be done to accelerate progress on
the goals and that does tend to bring us
back to gender because where the goals
struggle the most is where the needs and
status of women are given a low priority
and I personally believe that investing
in women and girls could well be the
breakthrough strategy we're all
grappling for to accelerate progress on
the MDGs because we see the investments
that we make in women and girls as being
intergenerational in their effects we
can see that the level of education that
a mother has will be a significant
variable affecting her own
children's later education attainment
and opportunities we can see the flow-on
effects of education for girls for the
future supporting a reduction in child
mortality and maternal mortality we can
see it improving better child nutrition
we can see it increasing women's ability
to move out of poverty there are just so
many spin-offs from women having access
to opportunity I attended a very
interesting lecture by professor Francis
Stewart of Oxford a couple of Friday
nights ago here at the UN in New York
she is one who has been a mentor for and
contributor to the human development
reports which UNDP produces each year
and she was producing empirical evidence
that when you look at what is associated
with successfully lifting human
development for country a common factor
appears to be good ratios girl boy in
education in other words where girls are
getting access to education this is
lifting the ability of a whole country
overtime to lift its level of human
development now the good news is that
the gender gap which has existed in
primary school enrollment that has been
narrowing in 1999 there were 91 girls in
primary school for every 100 boys that's
now 95 on the other hand we're seeing
progress on equal enrollment and
secondary education rather slow and some
gaps they're opening up for example
sub-saharan Africa the ratio of girls to
boys enrollment in secretary education
actually has been seemed to fall in
recent years so that is
and soon but one of the biggest concerns
and this will be quite a focus of debate
around the millennium development goals
this year is what is happening on
maternal health and the truth is not
enough donut bombard you with figures
but in 1990 the base year for the MDGs
for every 100,000 live births live
babies born there were four hundred and
eighty woman who died by 2005 that had
only reduced to 450 the Millennium
Development Goal target for 2015 is 120
well on the course we're on there's no
way that you could remotely reach that
goal but I really don't feel we can
passively sit by and say well isn't that
terrible that goal won't be met it is
appalling to me that somewhere in the
world a woman dies every single minute
from complications from pregnancy or
childbirth so we really do need to focus
on how can we support women's sexual and
reproductive health needs being met we
know that being able to give birth in a
clean place with a skilled birth
attendant can radically reduce those
mortality rates and we've got to focus
on very simple things like that I say
simple but of course they have to be
funded they have to be logistically
supported that people have to be trained
medications need to be got to where
they're needed what seems like a simple
intervention has a long train of things
that have to be sequenced to make it
happen but my basic point is that for
development to be sustainable it has to
meet women's needs as well we need to
expand women's economic opportunities we
need to strengthen the legal rights and
status of women and we need to ensure
that women's voices are heard and
decision making and those three areas
the three main areas looked at in a
recent report that I launched in dili we
you NDP's asia-pacific human development
report on gender and it states very
firmly that the under-representation of
women and the paid workforce has
significant negative economic
consequences not just for women but for
whole countries and suggests that
raising the proportion of women in the
paid workforce to the high levels seen
and a number of developed countries
would increase annual gdp in a number of
the asia-pacific countries of course
it's an understatement to say that when
women have decent work it's not only the
women who benefit their families and
their communities benefit a great deal
as well and by decent work let's also be
inclusive of the incredible potential of
women as entrepreneurs from the micro
level up but to be successful there's a
number of obstacles which often have to
be over come for example can they access
finance it's not unknown in many
countries for a woman to have to have
her husband's signature to open a bank
account it's not unknown for women to be
unable to hold title to land or to be
unable to inherent land and in the
developing world where so much of the
farming is done by women the inability
to actually control the title to the
land can be quite a a significant issue
so removing those barriers certainly
would help women's economic empowerment
these are areas that our development
program works and how can we narrow
those gender gaps and tackle
discrimination in the economy as
elsewhere we promote having women's
needs reflected and national development
planning looking at issues like how the
unpaid care work burden on women impacts
on development and what interventions
would lessen the load which women carry
one example there's been in West Africa
quite a lot of work done on supplying
diesel engines small-scale
village communities and often the diesel
engine can reduce the amount of time
which women spend on domestic chores by
2 to 6 hours a day and of course the
ability to access some electricity can
also help a micro business can help the
process of production when you say you
might say to me diesel what's
progressive about that of course many
things can make diesel biodiesel for
example I think going forward the
challenge will be to have ways of
producing the diesel which will be clean
clean ways to but when we think about
then pushing women's economic
empowerment we have to look at that
second issue identified in our report
and that is legal empowerment and we
work across a range of countries on
strengthening women's legal rights so
that they are consistent with
international norms and standards we
have an initiative legal empowerment of
the poor which works to expand the
access of poor people to justice so that
they can use the law to advance their
rights and interests undp host of the
commission to look at the legal
empowerment of the poor with a number of
eminent people aren't including former
Secretary of State Madeleine Albright
it's a good report and it's had a lot of
influence on the work that we do in
Liberia for example and in Mozambique
and Uganda UNDP has been supporting an
initiative around community land titles
with special measures to protect the
land claims of women and others so
vulnerable in the population now let me
come to the importance of participation
and decision making because I have to
say my personal experience is that until
you get a critical mass of women in
Parliament's and in decision-making
women's issues do not get priority
women's voices are too lonely too
isolated and in the case of my own
country i went into the parliament when
the numbers of women doubled from four
to eight very lonely small band
completely marginalized
by the time I left New Zealand usually
had close to a third of its MPs and a
woman it makes a tremendous difference
because the issues are brought into the
mainstream of political decision makers
attention so I'm very committed to
finding ways of supporting women to rise
to positions of that kind around the
world and when all else fails you have
to consider quotas you have to consider
reserved seats to break the mould to
show that women can do these jobs and do
them extremely well and undp does
support governments and drawing up
legislation on these issues I was
recently in Papua New Guinea where there
is one woman Member of Parliament she
happens to be the one woman minister and
she came to UNDP and said help I'm
lonely I would like some peers and so at
her request and was with the agreement
of government of Papua New Guinea we
have supported Dame Carol kevvu to draw
up a bill which would reserve 22 seats
and the Papua New Guinea Parliament for
women and she hopes to get the support
of her cabinet to take the bill to
Parliament that would take Papa New
Guinea from obviously having under one
percent of its MPs as woman to around
seventeen percent which would be pretty
close to the global average it's not the
thirty percent that was envisaged as an
international target but that's progress
so we obviously wish her well in Albania
we supported their the first-ever
legislative quota for women and their
recent parliamentary elections and that
lifted the level of women's
participation in their Parliament from
seven percent to 16.4 again it's short
of the International target but it
represents incredible progress these are
just some of the ways that we can be be
part of promoting women's voices being
heard
and I'm a great advocate for helping to
shatter the glass ceiling that woman so
often run up against and then pave the
way for other woman to to follow I
believe women's voices need to be heard
on so many issues that confront the
international community whether its
climate change the environment
international peace and conflict
resolution we played a part for example
in the run-up to Copenhagen climate
summit in the upskilling training
workshopping with about 500 government
women participants and NGO participants
so that they could make a good
contribution on form contribution and
many of them of course have taken that
back home and have been able to feed
into the debate there then there's what
we can do to promote the role of women
and peacekeeping and recovery from
crisis it's well accepted that women
need to be involved in this area why
well in today's conflicts civilians are
the most affected the majority of
refugees and displaced persons are women
and children women have perspectives
they have needs they have issues yet
they have been repeatedly marginalized
in the recovery from conflict and
disaster keeping the peace has
traditionally been something that blokes
do women have had very few seats at
negotiating tables too little say in the
planning and the implementation of
reconciliation processes yet they have a
great interest in it so we are certainly
part of the UN effort to involve women
more at every stage of the peacekeeping
peacebuilding peace settling process and
we can point to good examples of where
women have played critical roles in
conflict-ridden nations as agents of
change take Liberia where women made
major contributions to getting a
peaceful resolution of the conflict
they're pushing for the fighting
factions to be disarmed even
before the peace accord was signed and
of course that country went on to elect
Africa's first woman president which is
something of which they can be very very
proud in Somalia UNDP has worked with
women to support them to be part of
national reconciliation processes can't
be tougher than their including
supporting women being part of drafting
the new constitution we helped establish
a task force with the ministry of
women's affairs there so that somali
women's voices could be could be heard
but let me come to a very serious issue
and that is the issue of sexual and
gender-based violence which is such a
part of so many conflicts now and
unfortunately for many women that
doesn't end when a war or conflict ends
a patent is being established almost a
debasement of the society where this
horrible problem carries on the UN has
been very active in the Security Council
on the issue of addressing systemic
sexual violence and conflict and I'm
told Elizabeth that you took students to
the Security Council yourself to witness
the passing of resolution 1888 on sexual
violence there has just been the
first-ever un under-secretary-general
appointed to work on this issue of
sexual violence and conflicts so that
shows how seriously the
secretary-general and the system are
taking those issues she is margot
wallstrm a former Swedish a minister
most recently vice president of the
european commission in Brussels and I
think she will do a fantastic job our
part well we're one of many players in
this area but we do work for example in
countries like Democratic Republic of
the Congo where we've trained paralegals
and people who can advise and support
survivors of sexual
violence in their interactions with the
police and the courts and also we've
engaged with traditional community
leaders to help reintegrate the victims
of sexual violence back into their
communities in timor-leste UNDP has been
part of supporting the development of
specialized units within the police
there to prevent gender-based violence
now when we talk about recovery from
crisis focus my comments on the crisis
that comes from conflict and war but let
me now comment on the recovery from
natural disaster and use the specific
case of of Haiti itself which I know as
I said earlier the school has had a
connection worth and I understand back
in 2008 to students from this program
undertook a research project that was
looking at how the UN mission there was
responding to the pressures on Haitian
people of the high food prices and also
the aftermath of the previous disaster
which was the devastating hurricane of
of that of that year so now another huge
and terrible crisis obviously our part
is is early recovery UNDP is not a
humanitarian agency we're a development
agency but there's a point of crossover
that you have an emergency phase you
start to move into early recovery we
start there and we've started with job
creation programs which have been
basically called cash-for-work you might
say well why wouldn't you be paid of
your work that's the philosophy there
weren't too many jobs around porta
pranced after the disaster of that
earthquake and so we came in to work
with local organizations on job creation
to create temporary work clearing rubble
ree sorting seeing what could be reused
just just basic work like that so people
could get some sub cash income spend it
on the local stalls and market helped
revive the economy but there's some
important
at the same time so there's multiple
benefits from something something like
that now over the past few weeks we've
been involved as part of the effort to
do the post-disaster needs assessment
this is a very formal thing that happens
after a disaster in a developing country
the agencies come together UN World Bank
European Commission comes in the
Regional Development Bank to do this
formal assessment and fundamental to
this is to build back better build back
better in Haiti so that there's more
resilient to future shocks of all kinds
one of the key objectives we have is to
see that the future disaster risk
reduction measures are gender sensitive
we obviously concern that women and
girls and vulnerable groups should get
the protection and security that they
deserve and badly need and to see that
women's voices again I heard in the
recovery and reconstruction process and
you we do have around forty percent of
the people and the job creation programs
are actually women which which is good
pretty it's not fifty about 40 is
certainly start in this context so long
way to go on Haiti tomorrow at the UN
the donors will be asked for 3.86 four
billion dollars for the next 18 months
the total cost is estimated at 11
billion but a strategic decision has
been made not to ask for that right now
but to go for the three point eight four
billion get the work started and then we
will need to come back to donors again
it's obviously very very expensive can I
say one last word on the the issue of
the UN and what's happening with women
there is going to be a new agency to
promote gender equality set up it does
not yet have a name as talked about as
the composite gender entity well
obviously you can't go forward with the
you
in composite gender entity will have to
have a name that's that's catchy and
appealing but what it's going to do is
draw together four different parts of
the UN system into a strengthened agency
for women unifem which many of you will
know of in straw which is based on the
dominican republican does research on
women and then the people in the
department of economic and and social
affairs who service the committee on the
status of women and and also the office
of the special advisor on women so four
dots for women are being drawn together
into one composite agency and it's
expected to attract rather more funding
than unifem has in the past and we hope
it's going to be a big help in promoting
the advancement of women not only in
developing countries but actually
worldwide because let's not pretend
developed countries are perfect on any
of these issues and the UN Committee on
the status of women is very much looking
at the position of women around the
world so in conclusion as I was asked to
focus my comments around issues
pertaining to women in development
obviously I think that promoting the
rights of women is a good thing in its
own right should be done basic human
right equality is an important principle
to me but I can also say that if we
achieve that happy state of affairs it
would be very good for development we if
we don't include the whole population
the progress countries are making we're
really selling ourselves short and I
hope that's a message that those of you
who go into this field will take with
you when you complete your studies thank
you very much
thank you very much i can see students
are already lining up for questions but
but before we do this is the high 80
team but before we do that I just want
you to thank you very much for this very
inspiring so this we call for the
empowerment of women I must say having
been at the UN for close to 30 years and
hearing that finally there is an agency
after years as you know of negotiations
on this and also seeing the Security
Council resolution which came on
violence against women which Hillary
Clinton okay you know came to pass at
the UN with the Security Council is
really exciting um I have many questions
for you but I just wanted to tell you
that when I take students to the
Security Council I must say I'm a little
bit of shame it has improved but I
remember last year entering the council
with a group of 50 students or so and
seeing this council which was all men
and then looking at a picture of 1945
the first Security Council all men and I
thought but what are we doing wrong and
at some point Milan or bride had created
when she was the ambassador of the
United States at the UN had created the
g4 the girl thought they were for women
ambassadors for 192 countries and the
eye thing and they are doing much better
now but in New York it was always
difficult because it's the political
world they do better in Geneva with with
the humanitarian world but here it has
really been difficult but now there is
the ambassador of the United States who
is a woman obviously and there is the
ambassador of Nigeria and Brazil so we
are doing better in the council but you
know when they are not there and you
look at this Security Council and you
think so talking about the need for
women in decision-making process in the
in the political world it's still a
man's world and one of the questions are
hard before we really go to development
issues was to us you have been the prime
minister of New Zealand you talked about
the need for critical mass the difficult
in a way to play the game that the man
said when there is no critical mass and
I must say this has been my experience
at the UN in the political world how do
you do that are you have to survive in
the political world of men and at the
same time you would like to not to play
the game but to change the game and it's
extremely difficult so my question to
you and then I will open the floor to
students is what is it that as the prime
minister of New Zealand as the first
woman at the head of undp what is it
that you found the most difficult and
what do you think is your comparative
advantage university teacher I will
stand up speak so you ask a very very
interesting question because we're women
have been a rarity in positions like
Parliament or leadership there are there
is a glass ceiling and you have to break
your way through it and I found you know
I mean I'm a baby boomer I come out of
post-war baby boom in New Zealand we
were such a lucky generation we had
access to tertiary education the world
was our oyster it never occurred to me
that there was any barrier in the way of
anything i wanted to do i sailed through
university i became a lecturer when to
the Parliament button when I went to
Poland I started to hear things like oh
she won't win that electorate it's a
workingman's seat well the working men
most of them had wives but it was a
working man's seat you know she won't go
down at the return services club and the
bowling club because there were women's
bowling clubs as well and return service
woman but it was you know sort of
starting to raise these these kinds of
issues but anyway having got over that
and went on and then when I became the
leader of my party it all came out again
people said I she
never succeed as a leader because she
she doesn't drink at night with the men
you're right I sometimes talk about
going the New Zealand Parliament which
had all the characteristics of a
gentlemen's club you know when you walk
into one of these university clubs the
yale club or the harvard club downtown
leather armchairs and it's redolent of
sort of men only clubs around the around
the Western world and so I go into the
new zealand Parliament at the age of 31
discovered three forms of recreation one
exercise this muscle at the bar another
one exercised this muscle at the
billiards team and another one exercise
these muscles with the poker schools at
night well truly you know I was a young
woman out of university did any of this
appeal to me know so in a sense you know
you have to redefine the political
culture and over time you have to
educate the media that you're not going
to behave like that you're not going to
be one of those boys because that's not
you and it wouldn't you wouldn't be true
to yourself and whatever you are in
public life if you're not true to
yourself people see that they will see
that you put on an act in order to be
something so I think you have to be true
to yourself and takes a lot of Education
of your media and certainly when I when
I became the leader people that the
media complained her voice was too low I
actually got with a sore throat today so
it's particularly they don't like what
you where they don't like the way he is
cut I mean endlessly picky these things
ever said about men you know how many
men do you hear criticized for having a
high voice you know how many men's
haircuts dear here criticized in public
life well their suits I mean by and
large people are listening more to what
they say so you have to work quite hard
for your appearance not to be an issue
not to be a distraction so you know all
of those things have to be dealt with
but I like to think that as more women
deal with them as more women get to the
top these things become so obviously
petty silly and ridiculous that they
never raised again you know so you just
have to demonstrate by
and by the power of ideas and your
message i guess that that you can do the
job and you're going to do it your way
it's any way you can do it otherwise
you'll come across as a but there's a
bit funny that's my experience we should
open you have to know that usually and
you probably know i have big panels with
a lot of speakers these tonight i
decided to have just helen clark so that
you would have a chance to have a
dialogue with her and ask her all the
questions you have because if they are
two minutes because there is not enough
time so now it's your time and you've
got to just line up at the microphone my
enthusiasm is a reflection by interested
in your lecture which is very very
stimulating very very hopeful and
uplifting just to briefly echo something
that Professor lindenmayer said of
course I was one of the students with
with her in Haiti and I just wanted to
again emphasize on on behalf of the
students so just to thank you to kimball
Duke and and all the undp team in Haiti
and I just wanted to convey that as well
on behalf of the students just to
reiterate what Professor lindenmayer
said obviously my interest is is on
Haiti looking at the at the conference
upcoming tomorrow here at in New York
two brief questions you can choose to
answer either one the first is what can
be done in terms of improving the
economic empowerment of women if you can
provide additional details specifically
the entrepreneurial skills of women in
terms of leading job creation in Haiti
as we move forward and the second
question touching on on the issue of
natural disaster risk reduction and
environmental vulnerability in the PDA I
think close to the fifteen percent of
the budget is allocated towards natural
disaster risk reduction I was just
curious if you had any views or could
provide any insights on what role the
private sector could be playing in terms
of ecosystem restoration reforestation
through projects such as mango planting
or other types of fruit tree planting
that will both create jobs
in the agricultural sector and also
address these underlying environment
environmental vulnerabilities well I'm
not the expert on Haiti but obviously
the last two and a half months I've
learnt more about it than I could ever
possibly have foreseen and I think on
the the disaster risk management that
seemed to me to be two main areas one is
how you live around a hurricane prone
environment and the other is how you
live around an earthquake-prone
environment you know I mean I come from
a country which is also built on fault
lines you come to our Parliament
building in New Zealand it's all on kind
of stabilizers we have a lot of shakes
in our building goes like this you know
so one of the things clearly Haiti needs
going forward to try and proof itself
against that risk is a building code
which will be enforced so that it can
withstand shakes and it's very easy to
say that the code has to be designed and
then you know the system of inspection
and enforcement has to work and that
that's not going to be easy but it's
pretty basic there's no point building
back what was there that's not at the
essence of building back better so
that's the first point on the mitigation
around the the risk from hurricanes yes
you put your finger on it it's it's the
catchment issues that the rear
forestation issues you know Haiti's back
country needs something to hold the
water as it as it falls it's an it's
foresters strip down you ask about
private sector role I think the private
sector role is very important going
forward I mean clearly there's going to
be a lot of a lot of work for private
sector countries with companies with the
rebuild but one could envisage for
example that there might be some
interest in commercial forestry imagine
what the rain Haiti gets trees will grow
although the soil is heavily degraded as
we know but you know it may be that that
rear forestation which
you know over time for some form of
selective logging might be might be a
way forward so let's hope people look
for creative opportunities of that kind
when President Clinton was appointed a
special envoy by the Secretary General
last year one of his main interests was
in seeing if he could attract private
investment to Haiti because while it's
important I think to talk about the
economy from the the micro level up the
reality is that that no developed
country is without a strong private
sector and and some of that should be
international investment let's hope we
can also grow the domestic investment of
wealth base as well that's that's a long
term cause before we move to the next
question I just wanted to take you to
abuse the chair maybe and to ask you do
you know the to what extent have the has
the issue of women women be taken care
of or have been what is the importance
of it in the indie post-disaster need
assessment because I remember Clinton in
the Security Council when he came Bill
Clinton in September saying that this
was really important and there would be
a lot of important you know a lot of
attention given to the issue of women in
Haiti but when I look at the PD na I
didn't find that this issue was really
highlighting neither did I find that
really the soft issues like health
education had been put as priorities by
the government to the extent that this
is a government plan and we wear again
into the infrastructure and the
rebuilding of houses and the you know
which is a absolutely important I agree
but I mean where are those issues of I
mean the issue of women where is it
hidden in the PDA I would like to know
what is giving to happen tomorrow if
anybody is going to mention it at all as
a priority and regarding the
reforestation are you know the Haitians
cut the trees because of poverty
obviously and they need the trees
because they have no alternative kind of
source of energy so that's the way they
cook and
it's nice to replant trees but if we
cannot propose to them an alternative to
that they will continue to cut tree
because of poverty so is this issue
being looked at in a more comprehensive
way as you know as energy not only for
afforestation yes and after the 2008
Huracan there was work being put in
place to address the issue of
alternative energy because clearly the
forests have been cut down for fuel for
chuckle and unless you can provide a
different fuel source anything your
plant will will have the same fate so
alternative fuels are obviously very
important I mean I'll certainly be
mentioning the importance of women and
girls tomorrow but it may well be that
the P DNA has more of a focus on that
physical reconstruction but then you
come back to the long-term presence of
the UN development agencies the UN
country team and our work to promote
inclusive development green development
the needs of the more marginalized which
includes women and girls I mean it
brings me back to the previous question
which I didn't fully answer the first
part about what can be done on the
economic empowerment of women in Haiti
well let's start with girls and
education be great to get all curls back
into a schoolroom for a start let's
ensure that the the job creation that's
being done in the short term gives women
a fair shake let's look at the
possibilities for supporting women's
entrepreneurship and you know
microcredit course has its critics but
it's been pretty important in getting a
lot of women into small business and
trading activity let's look at the the
opportunities that come from the
reconstruction stage for women to be
skilled to be able to take the jobs I
think there's a whole lot of angles but
I suspect it's going to be the long-term
work of the UN country team and the
interested NGOs and donors
almost as ongoing business to be
addressing these issues when the
recovery reconstruction will have almost
inevitably a pretty heavy physical
emphasis but having said that I think
everyone will emphasize that unless what
is planned enjoys the support not only
if the government of Haiti but of
Haitian people it's not going to go
reefer so getting that by and support
consent is pretty important what
happened to Stephen okay Thank You mr.
Leclerc for presenting goes to your
views I have two questions actually a
one is about the gender issue and women
issue that you have raised being work
working in development world i work for
UN Population Fund and being in everyday
work involved in that i becoming a bit
of concerned with this if i may call its
of women ization of gender not in the
sense that the man should also be given
all those three points that you access
to education financial resources and
government but probably they can should
be given access to understanding why
involving women and giving that access
to women would be more beautiful for
everybody and in that case probably we
can avoid this notion of the guy who is
giving his signature for his wife to
open the account so that should not that
he probably start to understand it's not
part of life and my so the question is
should we also involve men in all this
adventure or or not I mean how we should
deal with that and the second equation
is on Heidi Heidi has proved that
sometimes unfortunately in development
board we are not very successful with
some countries because I EVT have been
receiving the
eight since the beginning of entering of
this notion of international aid and
still Heidi IIT is one of the most
poorest countries in the world it's
almost to the number that the women the
maternal mortality hasn't been improved
very much I mean it's almost the same
thing and it should we start thinking to
work some in different ways so that
after this that the IET can be improved
I mean this fragility of the state which
was always there and we were always
supporting the society to became more
stronger state but never succeeded in
them thank you well look on the to the
two questions yes of course the support
of men and boys is absolutely critical
to getting the changes for women if you
don't have that support you're not going
to be able to make the changes so men
men have to be involved and hopefully in
a positive way secondly on doing things
differently within and with Haiti I
think inherent in this approach after
this disaster there's a recognition that
there needs to be support for more
decentralized government that para needs
to be pushed out from port-au-prince
that the economy needs to be more
decentralized I think you'll find that
coming through is quite a strong theme
my understanding as it's been a country
where the capital has been pretty
dominant the government's be weak but
the Capitals been dominant and sucked in
people and and to resources resources to
the extent there's been resources so I
think you see a more more decentralized
approach but it is going to be very
important to support government having
the capacity to try to rise to the huge
tusks that are there not only the
central government but out in the
districts and localities as as as well
you know UNDP has four main areas of
and every single one of them is relevant
to Haiti crisis prevention and recovery
governance poverty reduction on mdgs
Haiti wouldn't be on track for single
mdg and then the climate environment
entity issues every single part of our
mandate is is highly relevant and we're
very committed to try and make a
difference in a systemic way I wondered
if you might come in on something I
failure a uniquely place to answer
having led our country for nine years
and now leading an agency that is
responsible for trying to address global
problems you mentioned at the start of
your talk that we're in an era of some
intractable collective global problems
things like financial crises food crises
climate change but if you observe
multilateral negotiations you seen
observe that states very often pursue
their own national interests and
sometimes this is at the detriment of
trying to achieve collective solutions
to global problems or to address things
that don't directly relate to their
material interests I don't think the
problem is that we can't address
collective issues if you look at the
financial crisis trillions were
mobilized in a very short space of time
to try and respond to that crisis but if
you look at other crises that are facing
us there hasn't been a political will to
actually address them now I wonder if
you might be able to comment because of
your background on some methods that we
might be able to employ to help states
and governments encourage them to
transcend their national interests and
start focusing on some of their
collective issues that we face mmm well
I think the the trick is to show the
connections between your national
interest and what's happening beyond
your Shores because you know the world
is actually very small the world is
shrinking we are very interconnected
and problems don't stay in a ghetto
right they don't stay behind national
boundaries they jump boundaries they
jump boundaries of states boundaries of
class ethnicity faith gender you know
once there's a concentration of problems
it doesn't stay there becomes becomes
our problem and one could think of of
many many examples of that you know for
example look at the migration debate
what drives migration out of the
developing world to the developed world
lack of opportunity so poverty
desperation then create problems on
borders with the the human misery for
those who don't make it across a border
whether it's land or sea the
exploitation often of those who do make
it over the border then the undercutting
perhaps of wage rates locally the you
know that there's just so many issues so
if you go back to what is the source of
the problem it's the push factor because
people haven't got the ability to to
make a decent living at home so that
should focus us on how can we support
that and deal with the pressures on on
the developed countries by by going back
to the heart of the problem it's a but
the same with the disease isn't it
disease doesn't stay behind national
boundaries of if TB gets a fresh lease
of life with these killer bugs it can be
on a plane and in any country any time
swine flu bird flu SARS etc you know why
do you need to support the building of
effective public health systems because
you can hopefully close down an epidemic
of serious illness before it before it
it really spreads causing misery not
only in a country but will be on the the
borders and think for example of natural
resource issues like the the world's
fisheries and the international issues
around that we're depleting our oceans
we can't deal with that on the national
level it's got to be dealt with
internationally
so there's just so many ways in which
our neighbors problem becomes our
problem whoever we are wherever we are
and I think it's up to political leaders
to try to draw those connections and say
look we can't blame people for you know
that the situation there inlets look at
the structural factors let's look at how
we could help address those because if
we can't address problems at source
they're going to be growing problems for
us in our enlightened self-interest but
from any moral or philanthropic
imperative it's in our enlightened
self-interest to support multilateralism
and end development and if you want to
go further on the enlightened
self-interest you know the truth is that
developing countries prospering people
having bigger incomes you know it's
that's larger markets for to be traded
in to traded across the demographics of
most Western countries are of declining
populations aging populations the growth
and vibrancy of population is in the in
the developing world huge markets if
people have money in their pocket so
again that that kind of enlightened
self-interest could be could be looked
at I mean what's what's spearheading the
international recovery at the moment
China India huge populations generating
demand rising middle classes let's hope
it translates more for people at the
bottom of the of the ladder as well but
my own country was the first Western one
to sign a free trade agreement with
China why did we do that we can see the
potential of China why wouldn't you want
to first mover advantage in a market
like that that's enlightened
self-interest for us but it will also
you know it's one of many tiny things in
our case which is also supportive of
China's development yes
thank you I'm not going to ask about
Haiti I'm a first year student in
development so I wanted to ask about
business and entrepreneurship as a way
to empowering women and I was reading
earlier about the partnership of undp
with sida in the turkey program for
building the business and technical
skills for the Fashion Week and many
turkey women are being empowered through
that and I wanted to ask you I
personally believe business empowerment
for women is a terrific way a tangible
result in actually accomplishing not
only mdg one related to poverty but
thereby because they're the backbones
order of their families in Southeast
Asia or Africa it's also mg 2 and m 35
satellite to ask you what is your view
into more of those partnerships or
public-private partnerships how the
private sector plays a role and for
those of us who are graduating and going
into the development what would be your
recommendation into the business factor
as in this topic with women oh I think
that's replete with opportunity because
you're right i mean entrepreneurial
activity you know rather than looking
for someone to give you a job that's
often not that easy in many places but
the opportunity to start a business to
get the skills to do it to support women
to do that the access to credit the
legal changes that can facilitate it you
know the mentoring and support i think
there's fantastic opportunity so you you
would know more about the initiative
turkey than I do because we have a
hundred and sixty six programs countries
around the world with with thousands of
different initiatives but from what you
described I'm pleased to hear that that
UNDP is and is involved with it and
particularly that high-end and fashion
it's an incredible area for women to be
to be getting into a very high value
area so no I think there's work to be
done and wish you well in developing a
career opportunity around
okay can you introduce yourself yes my
name is Allison Dubois V and I'm access
sip a student and actually employee of
undp so I would like to ask you a
question that doesn't regard IET or
development but thank first of all thank
you very much for your speech was very
inspiring especially when you talk about
your experience as a prime minister
entering and when you were entering the
parliament in New Zealand as the first
woman the gentlemen's club I was
wondering as being the first woman
administrator of the undp how are you
using this momentum to promote gender
mainstream and but not also in the in
the rest of the world but without within
the organization are using to promote
women leadership and retain women
employees that is still something that
the UN is struggling doing well here in
DP does have a agenda strategy in its
human resources obviously human
relations department staff management
and you know they're expected to to live
up to up to that and n nurture and
support women there's been quite a big
effort to increase the number of women
who are resident representatives and
resident coordinators which is of course
a very senior leadership position the
usually the top UN official in a in a
developing country and as you know at
the senior management level of the UNDP
women are extremely well presented
obviously the administrator is female
the associate administrators female we
have another three assistant secretary
general level positions that are females
as well so
think you know strong tone is set is set
from the from the top and that's
certainly important to me but you rely
on you know strong messaging and then
you your human resources people to drive
that strategy through can I ask you a
question to follow up on what you said
um how did you do it with a special
person to tea with the the resident the
coordinators I mean because when I was
at the UN they were not too many women
yet and then you introduce this exam I
believe where I think when they are
exams women compete very well you can
see how well they do and then I think
through that exam you attracted quite a
few women but can you just sail in a bit
how did you improve those numbers
because they were pretty low at some
point and I think the agencies are doing
so much better than the Secretariat the
UN Secretariat in terms of women because
you are the first woman at the head of
undp but the other agencies did pretty
well in terms of women being UNICEF or
unfpa or you know wh 0 with brutal on
and so on the way with your video FB has
own way and so on so the agencies do
quite well but the you are right that
this is one of the best job at the UN to
be a rezar appear sentative in a
peacekeeping operation so in
peacekeeping we did we didn't do well I
mean at some point there was simp simply
no special representative woman now we
have one in Liberia with a former
ambassador of Denmark and achieve
olestra and timor-leste exactly and
there are a few deputies special
representative coming but it's still
extremely difficult and the UN doesn't
do well for leadership and women so from
your experience at undp how did you
improve those numbers and what about you
lead program you have a lead program at
undp where sea bass students as a matter
fact can apply and be trained I think
this is fantastic it doesn't exist in
the secretary we don't invest in the
secretary in the staff as much as you do
as an agency so I wonder if you could
say what does it take to have women's
for a rest resweb well I think you're
right the agencies and funds and
programs are quite progressive illness
in the way in which they they do try to
attract in talent in an even-handed way
but some of the changes are which led to
this significant increase in woman as
resident reps obviously they've occurred
before I came but you're right there was
an assessment required very few
organizations require people to undergo
a full assessment or exam of you like in
order to reach a top position but this
was what was introduced in the
development system and there were people
who had been resident reps resident
coordinators before who failed it and
could not ever be posted again as a
resident representative but you may be
right that that may have been a factor
and woman coming up through women
thinking gosh I can have a go at that
you know I can get into that pool and
once in the pool of course the the woman
get you know absolutely fair
consideration and the way it's done as
it comes through an interagency steering
committee that different agencies have
reps on then it comes to me and I make a
decision what name to take to the
Secretary General but the you know it's
been quite a significant process I
should say to people that I know student
audience like this people come from many
different countries a number of
countries do support young people coming
into the funds programs and agencies
through the junior professional officer
program not all but but quite a lot and
basically the government concern puts up
the money Sam who's with me tonight you
came in did you come in as a GP oh no
you didn't but but South Africa doesn't
but anyway there's others around people
from Germany Sweden Denmark etc who came
in as as junior professional offices and
then got a foot on the ladder you came
in as a jpa which country Italy
fantastic yeah we'll see that and that
gives those countries really a leg leg
up and getting their nationals into the
system of they're prepared to sponsor in
wet we're talking to a wider range of
countries now about doing that for
example we're talking to China what it
wasn't China sponsored JP owes
fantastic we have very few people from
the People's Republic of China in the
international stream of the organization
so it is a way to get in at the bottom
level good evening thank you for coming
here tonight I wanted to ask you what
you see is the comparative advantage of
unity p visa V many other development
actors and many of them have a lot more
money also than UNDP and then also may
be related to that given that
coordination is one of the greatest
challenges a coordination of these
development actors how do you see undp
addressing this challenge in particular
well no one else in the UN system has
more money than UNDP because with a big
agency and the lead agency with a wider
presence and a far bigger budget than
anybody else we do we do work in 166
countries we have 135 country basis some
are multi-country officers obviously and
in a sense that's a comparative
advantage in itself because we have a
global network there's a lot of agencies
which cannot be resident in a country
undp will represent their interests it's
as simple as that so there's defect of a
leadership role from being the big
agency but more than that undp formally
is also leading the coordination system
so the UNDP resident rep is also the
resident coordinator for the UN in
country coordinates the country team has
a support office around that and we take
that pretty seriously because the basic
messages that will get more development
impact if we work together rather than
have a whole lot of agencies beavering
away on their little but we need to work
across agencies and just to give you an
example of what that can mean I went to
the ILO and Geneva last last week
speaking to their governing council
because you NDP's Executive Board has
direct
that we should very actively support ILO
with the global jobs pack which is
exciting but we need to work together on
that and ILO of course it isn't resident
in most of the world's developing
countries but we are so in a sense we
use their technical expertise in country
to roll out programs and initiatives so
that that's that's pretty important to
us but in terms of other comparative
advantage we have our areas of mandate
they determined by our board and they
are and you know there's four areas i
mentioned crisis prevention and recovery
there aren't you know other agencies in
the UN system with with that
comprehensive mandate nor governance
another specialty the climate
environment energy issues where the only
development agency with with that as a
specific mandate but we need to work
closely then with the UN Environment
Program and others whose work will have
a bearing on earth then poverty
reduction MDGs again a core part of the
mandate so those those are all things
where people look to UNDP and so if you
want to be active in these areas you
where the partner Anita and I wanted to
ask you following up on the coordination
questions about the dynamic between
security and development at the UN and I
wanted your frank assessment on how
those two branches work together we know
about integrated peacekeeping missions
but we understand that sometimes it's
hard for one to inject their interests
into the other could you talk about that
yes it can be difficult because you know
if you take a situation like Afghanistan
you've got a UN country team they're
working on trying to work on the sorts
of things I've been talking about
tonight but they're in a war zone and
there's a UN mission there and the un
missions mandate from the Security
Council is to you know liaised closely
with NATO which you know NATO after all
has the mandate for the Internet
security assistance force from the
Security Council so almost immediately
you've set up tension haven't you
because you've got the humanitarian and
development people who don't want to be
linked to anything that's linked to a
military operation and that is played
out in a number of countries this
country's I've visited where you know if
you get them in the same room the people
from the UN military mission and the
development humanitarian agencies will
be like that in great great disagreement
so when you try to integrate these
missions it can be difficult however I
mean the you know there's various
degrees of success with that some
missions have outstanding leadership
which is fully inclusive of and
empathetic with and understanding the
needs of the humanitarian and
development agencies and that works
pretty well but sometimes you get strong
personalities on both sides it's just a
clash and that then exacerbates that
underlying tension so I'm tempted to say
it will ever be thus yeah for the
students who don't know what an
integrated mission is it's a term west
with you used in peacekeeping operation
because you have the peacekeepers and
you have the special representative at
the top and in the past you just had the
peacekeepers and now you have the
agencies who are also under the under
the leadership of the special
representative and as Helen was saying
you know the peacekeepers the
peacekeeping operation takes its mandate
from the Security Council and the
humanitarian people the agencies don't
so that's the first source of problem
and also this paranoia issue that you
know immaculately interventions so to
speak that a lot of humanitarian people
have and they don't want to be seen with
soldiers doing what they do they think
that it really is counterproductive for
them so there are lots of issues it was
an idea that it Brahimi recommended in
his report to make a connection between
security and development and it started
with Sierra Leone in two thousand
whether that has worked a lot at the UN
is linked to personalities as you said
and if you have somebody in UNDP and
somebody in peacekeeping who don't agree
on on many things as it happened in
Haiti well then the mission is not
integrated and it doesn't work and it
create a lot of tension so they are good
good examples and bad examples of this
integration but I agree with you it's
not really yet there so yeah next hi
thank you for coming I wonder if you
could speak about the challenges if
there are any special challenges to
empowering women and development in
extremely traditional societies for
example I've spoken with a lot of people
who have served in Afghanistan in one
capacity or another and a common
attitude seems to be like you don't you
don't go into Afghanistan and start
talking to people about sending girls to
school unless you want to get a lot of
people hurt you better deal with their
understanding of right and wrong unless
you just want to take casualties and and
specifically do you think that there is
there like a tipping point at which it
becomes a it becomes easier like some
stage in the process where it becomes a
lot easier to approach people in general
about empowering women well I think it's
important not to not ever to come in and
impose things I think it has to what you
do has to be working with people and in
the case of the issues we're talking
about tonight it's working with the
women there will be women's voices
struggling to be heard working to
support them to be heard to inject their
perspective on how things could or
should be done and you'll you'll find in
all societies incredible woman whoo hoo
you know with with some support can
articulate on behalf of the voiceless
but I don't I don't think you can come
in and impose a set of values you know
think it's got to come from the bottom
up but you can work work with that and
then to come to your question about a
tipping point at a certain point you get
momentum it becomes more normal for
girls and women to be doing certain
things that encourages others
you know I mean look let's not think
that these these issues foreign to
developed societies either I mean I was
the first woman in my family to to go to
university I would say that really
probably up until the 1980s in New
Zealand many families wouldn't have
thought supporting their daughters the
university would have been a priority at
all you know so attitudes have changed
class to my country first and in this
country maybe not fast enough I mean as
a woman anywhere near being president of
the United States of America ask
yourself what are some of the real
barriers that women face in a range of
societies so I just regardless as as
work in progress but you know where
where my heart is in supporting women to
have their voice heard and to have your
voice heard you have to be in a decision
like instructor whatever that structure
is thanks are coming um I don't study
woman or development so I might
introduce yourself my name is cat
Thompson I'm as a doctoral student
education policy at Teachers College
here but i actually have done some work
on new zealand i guess i'm very
interested in your point where you made
the connection between improving the
role of women and the connection between
decentralization and the role of women
and what I study myself is the
appropriate venue for policymaking
things like social policy or public
policy and the jurisdictions between
federal and state provincial or state
levels and local regional levels and I'm
wondering if you could expand a wee bit
on the role of decentralization that you
mentioned earlier in bringing decision
making to the localized level and
hopefully incorporating more women in
that process and then like you you know
ideally an outcome being that you would
have improved the situation across any
any social policy area for example so I
want and I want to know as well as that
is is tied to 20 years of
decentralization in New Zealand with
education for example is part of why you
mentioned that earlier mm thanks well I
think you make a very important point
that often the entry point for women and
decision making is precisely at the
local level and of a look at my own
country's experience women were starting
to enter local government in significant
numbers long before they got into the
Parliament and significant numbers so it
it was a training ground for some woman
who went on but it was also I suppose
the fact that women were in local
government mainstream women's
participation so then there are
expectations that women can do it at
other at other levels as as well and so
I think in principle the process of
decentralization of you know greater
competence to the lower level
sub-national levels of government will
be positive for the empowerment of women
that the barriers for women going from
having very little representation to
some will be lower at the lowest level
and they were at the highest higher
levels now give the case of India again
India did I mention in my talk is
debating at the moment having a third of
all the seats in parliament reserved for
women it's passed through the upper
house one hopes that we'll go through
the lower house but since 1992 their law
has required that one-third of all the
women on the local councils these local
village level councils are women and
there's quite an interesting study done
of a couple of the states where women
actually came to be the majority on the
council's and these these councils
immensely more likely i think sixty
percent more likely to prioritize water
schemes and water initiatives in clean
water you know women addressing very
very basic basic needs I mean think
about hierarchy of basic needs we need
food we need shelter we need water etc
whereas councils can with a majority of
Manhattan prioritized these things
nearly as much the evidence points to
that in terms of empowerment of women
again
linking things in India with the
National Rural Employment Guarantee
Scheme there where the rural poor are
guaranteed their hundred days minimum
work a year at a minimum wage the
decision-making on what jobs are done
for that work has pushed out to the
village council level and so you can
link them to the woman having an input
into what are the jobs that are going to
be done in the community what are the
priorities and I must say where I went
to look at the scheme in action and saw
a woman working it was precisely around
water initiatives so now I think you
raise an important point
decentralization in principle will be
positive for women's entry to
decision-making I'm Michelle ow I'm an
alumna here at ciba Thank You professor
Linda buyer for convening this
opportunity and thank you helen for
coming to speak with us taking the time
to speak with us today my question is I
guess it's a little bit more personal um
I was really excited to hear that
there's going to be a new super women's
organization at the UN that hopefully
will be more powerful and certainly I
think it's necessary to have a dedicated
organization for issues like rape used
as a weapon of war or maternal mortality
rates high maternal mortality rates but
I think to your point about raising
critical mass I think it's really
important to have women in mainstream
power structures and decision-making
structures whether it's in finance or
politics and as someone who successfully
kind of reached the top and what what
what are some of the strategies or the
culture changing tactics that you you
you mentioned and what what is the
culture that you feel feel like you had
to kind of overcome were you always a
champion of women's issues were you
always aware of how important it it how
important
role of women is in development I just
wanted to get kind of your personal
perspective on how you came to realize
the importance of women in development
well in terms of personal experience you
know the sort of the wave of women baby
boomers who went into politics in New
Zealand did have tremendous support from
other women you know women did to
organize to to support other woman and I
think that was that was very very
important and I do think that you know
women women's networks are very powerful
and in supporting women and you know in
every sort of stream really over my
lifetime of address countless women's
organizations women and businesswomen
and the law women on the currency women
and education and health etc so I think
all of the networking is is extremely
important but yeah look look I come out
of a sort of strong social democratic
social and economic justice background
and you know just I mean it's
fundamental to me that that women have
equal opportunity and equal rights and I
apply that to my job and development as
I applied it to to leadership and
involvement and in my own country it's a
strong value basis that I'm coming from
I just want you to ask you about about
this MDGs to what extent do you think
that member states really have come to
the realization that they cannot reach
the MDGs without the women particularly
in Africa because they it's so important
in a way that they are involved and that
we do something for the women if we want
to reach this mdg do you have the
impression that in the international
community this is a new paradigm which
has sank in the minion peacekeeping it's
coming more and more you have this you
know group of indian policemen in
liberia which got a lot of reviews
recently in the press showing why it is
important to have women in peacekeeping
because women in the
so many women are raped they need women
to minute they have been there has been
a lot but I was wondering about it's
nearly a new paradigm that you would you
know you would bring development you
could achieve those goals through the
women and how much do you think this is
really in the discourse of the
international community and related to
this question then whether any women
working on the PDA on Haiti will ask you
question is it in the discourse as the
paradigm accepted I'd say early days
early days I mean I mentioned in
virtually every speech I gave that we're
not going to achieve development goals
unless we cut women into the equation
seems very obvious to me it seems very
obvious to me the breakthrough strategy
would be investing in women and girls
but are you asking me is that University
recognized no because if it was people
would be acting on it and they're not so
those of us and leadership roles in the
UN have a duty to get out there and bat
for this and I I must say the
secretary-general makes very strong
speeches on women and women's equality
and participation and so on and I think
you know that's fantastic so you know
there's a lot of us out there with us
mrs. obey that at the UN Population Fund
or an veneman has been with UNICEF he is
a lot of a lot of strong voices for
women and we we are endeavouring to be
heard so thank you for providing an
audience to at least listen to do this
because I think it's pretty fundamental
to making progress hi my name is
Stephanie uh I'm from New Zealand than I
work in New York and that's why I'm here
um I wonder if you think that gender is
a unique fracture point for developing
policy around to bring people into both
in the UN and other places there's all
kinds of obviously other fracture points
like class race ethnicity cast all of
those things but is gender unique among
those and
if you write policy that brings women in
where they went before you achieve a lot
of other goals that break down some of
those other kind of identity bearing I
think simply because of women are half
the world so it's sheer scale I mean I
just when you have a group that of that
size and the world population that
doesn't enjoy a quality of opportunity
anything you can do to to support that
group will have a very very significant
impact now in saying that I don't want
to understate the significance of the
other fracture points that you mentioned
as well because in our mandate we
advocate for the poor and marginalized
and do some disempowered across the
range of areas whether the
marginalization stems from disability
faith ethnicity being in an indigenous
group that doesn't enjoy full rights in
a society gay community I mean we are on
the side of those who don't enjoy equal
equal status and try to support the
advancement of their rights on a global
basis
everything more question yes
thank you for be here tonight I enjoying
speech a lot I have a a one simple
question about the China American in the
UN and when what do you think the
relationship among China America and
Chad un thank you political relationship
and economic relationship hmm i found i
must say that china has been a good
supporter of the UN system you know that
china respects the UN and is very
constructively engaged in it you know
China wants the UN to work I think China
takes the approach that it needs peace
to develop basic as that and nothing's
been more important than trying to raise
the standard of living but you don't do
that if you're having to spend a lot of
money on on conflict war etc so i would
say from from my perspective China's
role has been very constructive he is
the praise
okay I think time is up I just wanted to
ask you Helen you have in front of you
young women who are thinking of maybe
working for development working for UNDP
and so on if you had to give them to
advice about this issue of women about
you know how to really make it in a
man's world still particularly in the
political work what would you say to
them tonight what is your message to
them well I think I think you have to
set a goal the goal is nothing you're
going to meet it every time aren't you
so what you want to achieve you have to
have a goal your goals might change over
time of course but you must have a goal
you must have something that you're
striving for in us to you know have an
have an ambition to to achieve something
for yourself or for others and of course
and development you can have the happy
combination of both the actually
contributing back into the society as
well as finding fulfillment yourself in
a very satisfying career so it's a
question of being goal focused I guess
goal one for student is to successfully
complete a degree and I should say that
to get into the international stream of
of the UN you have to have a master's
degree that's basic you can't be looked
at below that that level for the men of
these these sorts of careers but be goal
focused complete your studies and be be
prepared to climb a letter to where you
want to go because as I said in the
course of my remarks and anything that's
worthwhile requires hard work dedication
and determination it doesn't come easily
actually and don't expect it all to be a
you know a sort of easy path I mean to
get to the sort of jobs I've done you
would take a lot of knocks I sometimes
so there's so many arrows are my back
there's no room for any more but you
know you have to have a sense of
perspective about that a bit of a sense
of humor but a sense of tolerance and
one thing you have to tolerate us fools
gladly you know the English phrase
he doesn't tolerate fools gladly will
you have to in public life you know you
meet a lot of fools actually so but you
just got to keep that sense of sense of
purpose sense of sense of perspective
and you know if I went on from that I'd
say to to everyone here that you know
when you're in pursuit of these goals
and where you want to go you know don't
don't go after it's so hard that you
leave no balance in your life this
applies to men and women that you can
become a completely burnt out shell if
you don't make time for yourself and
your family and your friends and your
community there's got to be some work
life balance you know people people
going to eat property they've got to
sleep I've got to have their have their
close relationships you've got to look
after all these things so that's that's
my lessons from from life I must say
well with this recommendation less than
experience i want to thank you very much
for coming I knew that tomorrow is a
very busy day for you with the UN and
Haiti and so on and we are really
particularly grateful that on a rainy
night like this with a program that you
have you came to see / to share your
perspectives on development thank you
very much
you